the dangerous winter storm moving across
the South this morning it is now blamed
for at least eight deaths this is a
system that continues to Pummel millions
in Texas and Arkansas temperatures are
below freezing in much of the region
with cold weather blanketing almost the
entire country Jason Allen from our
Dallas Fort Worth station KTVT is in
Fort Worth this morning Jason what do
you seeing
good morning David there is a very cold
light rain that is still falling here in
North Texas this morning it is adding to
the ice that's been collecting on the
trees and the power lines also to that
ice the slush the very slippery
conditions out here on the roadways and
that is keeping most businesses and
schools closed here for the third
straight day
one after another after another cars
proved no match for roads coated in ice
in and around Dallas and Fort Worth
Fort Worth Police have responded to more
than 200 car crashes since Monday
afternoon and across the state there
have been at least six Road fatalities
Dallas officials have urged people to
stay off the roads but some residents
had no choice I need formula for my
newborn so I have a little bit left but
just in case the roads are bad tomorrow
again I wanted to get some more the
crippling ice storm has caused travel
Mayhem and frustration at DFW where 75
percent of flights Wednesday were
canceled we got off
to rebook another plane we rebooked it
and within 30 minutes it was canceled
while in Austin
trees buckling under the weight of the
ice bringing an unfamiliar sound to some
and I thought it was car wrecks I came
out to investigate and saw branches on
the ground
[Applause]
those falling branches made some Texas
neighborhoods impassable and plunged
hundreds of thousands of customers into
the dark we decided to just pack up call
a friend and knowing that it's probably
going to start getting colder and colder
as the night goes
right now about 390 000 customers here
don't have any power the good news
temperatures this morning are hovering
just below the freezing Mark it's
expected to keep warming into the
weekend and melt some of this ice away
Tony
Jason Allen of KTVT thank you very much